[Music]
celebrate
what up guys it's January 8th happy week
to you wherever you are
it is the Saints plate I got to see my
Saints win I'm sorry if you're a
Panthers fan it was a pretty exciting
weekend of football you know it's been
it's been it's it's just nice to watch
them boys get out there and get wild you
know I feel like they make this league
kind of soft and maybe eventually
they'll have a new league a new type of
NFL or something that'll pop up that'll
be more violent you know who have Tigers
out there somebody you know maybe they
got a chimpanzee at half at midfield and
he's on both teams because a chimpanzee
will eat your nuts right out of your
ball sack I mean just like - you know
just like two olives
I bought that wild boil just dude he'll
pop your bag open and eat your nuts
right in front of you and chimpanzees
will do that they're very violent
animals I'm not a violent animal I don't
think so sometimes violence sometimes I
don't think so I wasn't a dog who
[ __ ] tired to be violent you know the
craziest like you know one night there
was some guy outside who was you know
sitting out there just revving his car
in the middle of the night and I grabbed
a couple of limes out of my fruit bowl
and just threw him off the balcony and
hit his van a couple of times and that
that's really my level of violence right
now throwing limes at somebody you know
in a shady van from about 50 or 60 feet
away safely from a second-floor balcony
at 4:00 a.m. that's where I'm at with
violence it's January 8th it's January
8th happy Monday hope everybody had a
good weekend that was Spencer growl the
Spencer growl band with celebrates back
to that original the original theme
music there and and it's good man we got
a lot going on the Golden Globes are on
right now I'm not
you know I'm just I'm a little for me
I'm a little you know I'm in Hollywood
cuz I'm here I'm out here fighting my
fight you know and doing you know I want
to have my I want to put my stake in the
ground for my career in my comedy
whatever those stakes may be you know I
want to continue to you know put those
pegs into the soil but you know I feel
like the the film films aren't as good
as they used to be for me and sometimes
I don't know if that's because I'm
disconnected if I'm getting older or if
movies are just bad these days but also
like Hollywood is so sometimes it is so
judgmental you know there's so it's just
so much judgment a lot of times and not
as much empathy even though it's just
it's always preached preached that
there's so much empathy it's you know
it's a business and it's a dirty dark
business that's what's going on out here
in Hollywood it is and I think a lot of
businesses are but there's so much money
out here that man when you add in more
money and you edit that's when the dark
arts that's when the dark arts really
start to bloom and they start to just
grow up your your skeleton like spines
and they grow from your bank account to
to your heart and next thing you know
there's these vines that are just
wrapped around you know just making a
Bermuda Triangle just just triangulate
in you and money and the dark arts and
that and that can be you know that can
be dangerous when you got that much
money on the line you know danger
usually lurks where there's a lot of
money danger usually lurks where there's
a lot of money so I mean I want to be
look I want to be well you know I wanna
I want to achieve I want to succeed I
want to get mine as they say you know
and I want to make a lotta yeah I want
to make money you know yeah I want to be
successful I want to achieve my goals
but I often also wonder how much money
do I want to make you know even before
he
made it I wonder that you know what
level do I want to be at I don't want to
be where I'm where I don't have the
ability to still believe in what I
believe in where the money on the other
side of that teeter-totter on the other
side of that totter is so great that
it's that's peeling me up off the earth
the foundation the soil of my values and
what's important to me you know and and
then while I'm still figuring those
things out what are what's important to
me you know it's uh it can be a scary
universe when you're still learning
what's important to you and when that
money's getting heavy on the other side
of that totter because it'll lift you
man it'll lift you you know a lot of
this business out here they you know
people get picked of her for celebrity
because they're the perfect advertising
tool you know they you know companies
and these you know the the Gepetto's the
people behind the scenes that are that
are moving these Pinocchio's in these
pinocchio-itis they see oh this this
person is the face this person this
person is the face for this let's use
them and that's got to be you know it's
it's got to be it's just wild there's
just a lot going on in there so I want
to always be cognizant in my mind of how
much do I need you know at what point is
uh is do I have too much and I think a
lot of that is you can keep me I mean
there's a lot of great people out there
it seem like they make a ton of money
and also give away so much money you
know you always hear about Bill Gates
said the man spends most of his day
these days giving away money and I hope
that you know if the powers that be in
the universe see that I achieve great
wealth I hope that at the same time they
see that I achieve the desire to want to
help others and
want to to share because man that will
fill your heart account up
I want those I want that big balance in
my aortas you know I want my I want I
want to I want my heart to be bubbling
with the joy of doing something not just
for myself because man I'll get trapped
in myself you know I'll get trapped in
myself a lot and sometimes that can be
scary it can be scary sorry I don't mean
to start out on such a why you know a
heavy note there but I've just had I've
had some stuff going on in my life where
you know where I've you know I've been
kind of in and out of this you know this
you know dating in this relationship
where you know sometimes I'm just afraid
to kind of commit to it and I'm afraid
of I don't even know what I'm afraid of
sometimes you know I guess I'm just I've
never been you know I don't know if I've
ever really trusted somebody fully in my
whole life and I guess it's almost like
how do you even it's like doing
something you've never done before like
if somebody asked you to you know drown
yourself in a bowl of gravy
I'd be like nah you know I'm not gonna
do that but if they're like oh man this
is good gravy and when you get down to
the bottom and you can't even breathe or
nothing it's just gonna feel awesome
it's gonna feel great I would still be
like that's crazy you know do this is
there do this gravy have a lifeguard you
know where's the lifeguard tower around
this gravy you know but then that's what
I think it is sometimes of jumping into
that you know it's why I have trouble
getting into relationships and staying
committed and staying steadfast I think
just cuz I've never done it I've never
done it my whole life and it's not even
like oh we'll just try it you know you
you know you've dated and you've been in
relationships before
but I've never been come ever known I've
never wanted to know or believe a
hundred percent that this can be
something amazing I've never been able
to I don't think and then and I want you
know I feel like I want to but I don't
even know how to and so that's why I say
it's like getting it's like it's like
somebody saying hey get on get get down
in this gravy cuz I can't breathe gravy
so my mind is telling me you don't know
you can't breathe gravy you know you're
not an amphibian you know you're not a
gravy amphibian you can't breathe gravy
but they're saying that it's so good
when you have that connection and that
you know that uh that that reciprocated
love that you can have with you know in
a relationship that is that that you can
really have in a trusting relationship
and for some reason for me it's just
really hard it's hard to just step out
into that love that sauce that love
gravy and just let myself submerge and
go down in there and be in there and
it's just because I've never done it
I've never done it you know and it might
be a wild correlation but I'm just I'm
trying to iterate to you how foreign it
feels to me to be in a in a committed
relationship or committed environment so
the anyway some of that's just been on
my mind and heart you know and we had a
caller that called in about it and and
I'll play that call right now and I want
to thank you guys for hitting the
hotline and that is nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three if you
have a thought or idea a response to
something that happens during this
podcast if you need help or if you need
somebody to share whatever's going on
with your life feel free to reach out to
the hotline and leave us a voicemail
this was that call that came in here we
go JP damn mm I'm a 35 year old male
who's been married two times man for my
second marriage and the second one's
going pretty successful so far
this is JP from Alabama thank you for
calling JP onward I just wanted to
address your fears being in a
relationship I think really man I'm like
I said I'm a plan I don't want to come
off as an [ __ ] here but I think
you're just trying to be in a [ __ ]
about it man and somebody who's been
through some [ __ ] with women always
worth it in the end seems like it's me
if you get out of it alive you know I
mean what's the worst gonna happen who's
gonna get a divorce
maybe you got a baby you got to pay for
so not really that big a deal man life
goes on I mean you ain't even taking no
risk as was in your comedy when he ain't
out doing drills Jane out doing alcohol
and whatnot so well you might as well
take a risk your love man if you love
this girl you like being around her you
need to show her that you want to be
around Hey yeah and that was the call
that kind of had guests having me
thinking about that no no I appreciate
that call JP you know I love the part
this yeah you got no real risk you know
set maybe what a divorce maybe a baby
but you know what I mean if the baby's a
product to love then yeah I guess that's
not a huge risk you know and if you know
that you're okay with taking care of a
child no matter what that's not a huge
risk but yeah I don't know sometimes
what my uh it's just it's so it's just a
its innate it's like somebody telling
you that you can swim that's what it's
like here's the correlation I think it's
like trying to tell somebody that they
can that they can they can swim but they
have no idea how to swim that they don't
even believe you that they could even be
out in the water I think that's what
it's like you know so yeah but that's a
good point you know I'm not out of here
taking what risks are my taking I don't
know you know it makes me feel a little
bit uh not shame to myself but it makes
me feel a little bit like a you know you
said it first like of a jean bra like
Aegina you know like that warm wallet
you know like that wild canal you know
like Joseph
Conrad wrote about you know that wild
canal out there that RIT whatever it was
that dark river whatever he was writing
about yeah it makes it's uh it's just
scary I don't know why it's so scary to
me but you're right maybe I gotta just
get out there and just you know I think
some of it is when I get into real heavy
in a relationship or if I really care
about someone it just you know and I
know a lot of guys have this you know
this problem because my friends are
talking to me about it all the time
those intimacy issues you know just like
I just struggle with wanting to be you
know then it's like I get so much
anxiety because it's such a foreign
territory that you know I just don't
want to be intimate you know it's almost
like I don't want to make that last
reach out of my soul you know and hit
them with that route you know I don't
want to pop that sex root you know and
make that big linked up you know I'd
rather dink and doink out here in the in
the wilderness you know I'd rather you
know find a crazy bareback behind a
cactus you know and pop off a nut but
when it's just when it gets you know
when you're right there and you meet an
animal in the woods and you y'all are
dancing and y'all are maybe twerking and
showing each other y'all's you know
y'all's real you know showing each other
y'all's warts and showing each other's
y'all's dirty wounds and doing sayin
things in front of each other you don't
say to other animals that's when that's
when I think after when I it's just some
intimacy stuff man I just I struggle in
that universe man
I struggle and it's some of that [ __ ] I
think it's just that it and dude
sometimes it even goes like there have
been times in my life even like I've
never had a good I've never had a good
idea of what my relationship was with
people even it's even with friends I
could be hanging out with a friend on a
vacation their family could take me on a
vacation with them and I'm still
wondering if this person is
my friend or not like there's just
something that there's some evaluator
inside of me that just is constantly
unsure if the connection that if that is
very obvious if somebody else looks over
at us and me and my buddy are out there
playing in the water
you know we're heterosexually out there
just throwing a frisbee or throwing a
football it looks normal you know
they're like oh those two kids are
friends right sure or if we're out
drinking at the you know floor bama
lounge or whatever it's some bar you
know it's like oh those guys are buddies
those guys are friends but to me there's
some little thing inside of me that just
can it never it's always asking me like
is everything okay with this friendship
is this a friendship is there's just
this there's this broken little chip in
me you know so that's just I mean I
guess and I'm not depressed about it I'm
at this point in my life right now where
I am trying to you know I'm trying to go
to more like different types of meetings
and different spend time with with
buddies and talk about how I'm what's
going on with some of us my fears so
that I'm not just sitting there holding
my fears like I'm at this poker game and
I just you know and I got a full house
of [ __ ] fear but I'm afraid to even
show my cards you know I don't I just
don't want I don't want to do that
anymore I want to try and take action
you know I want to try and take action
and I don't really have a new year's
resolution but I have you know if I just
sit there and when I start thinking I'm
no good when I get into my I need to
take action I need to take action I need
to move my feet before I move my brain
because my brain will outsmart me or
will dark art me into thinking that
something is wrong even if it's not even
if it's not I know I may I'm rambling
some here but you know that's sometimes
you gotta sometimes we ramble you know
sometimes I just want to be a big girl
laying in bed eating cookies snacking
out and worrying and just watching damn
Oh
Zork are watching the new Dave Chappelle
comedy special you know sometimes I
don't want to have to be this badass
sometimes I don't want to have to be but
but that's you know I don't know that's
some of the stuff that's going on but
let me get more positive let me try to
boost up here I want to thank everybody
from fighter in the kid you know I was a
and that's a podcast where they had this
man who is a fighter and he got he got
beat up and he got attacked a couple
times and he couldn't fight anymore
because his brain couldn't handle it he
was on the brisk of freakin getting that
you know a brush with that tis 'm and so
his brain you know told him we got to
shut it down and so he quit fighting and
he met up with this other man who's kind
of aging but he's just you know a sweet
funny guy and got strong legs the other
guy and they have a they have a podcast
comedian and their names are Brendon and
Brian in the podcast is called the
fighter and the kid and one of them uses
moisturizer and one of them needs
moisturizer and they had me on their
podcast this year and we and I got
picked as the guest of the year so that
was cool that really made me you know
that was that that made me feel good
because that you know their listeners
voted so I want to thank everybody who
who supported that and listened to that
and go listen to those guys if you
haven't you know because when I go into
that type of environment I'm just so
grateful to be in environments now where
I'm just hanging out with other guys
sometimes and I'm feeling okay you know
because as a kid and as a you know a lot
of times I don't have that a lot of
times I just have this thing in my brain
telling me that something's always wrong
but but that was that was a blast and I
want to thank anybody that voted for me
on that and supported me on that and
that's called the fighter and the kid
and you can check out their podcast I
want to let you know right now that gray
block pizza is on the it's on Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach and
they got that hitter so if you want
something in you that's good go to grey
block pizza in Los Angeles Pico
Boulevard get the
also I have a couple dates coming up
this weekend I'll be at the Brea Improv
in Brea California
it's Brea it's like bread but without
the D think about it like that
January 8th through 20th I'll be at the
new comedy club Jacksonville Florida
February 8th through 11th Harvey's in
Portland February 16th through 18th La
Jolla at the Comedy Store
February 22nd through the 24th fantasy
springs casino out there in Indio and
April 6th and 7th Tampa Florida at Rock
Brothers brewing and all of those links
should be up and clickable on theof on
coms last tour by Tuesday oh yeah what a
weekend my Saints one that lifted me up
that lifted me up my Saints one I was
happy about that we had some great calls
that came in I think what else has been
on my mind you know I just uh you know
just a regular just you know just life
just trying to be active just trying to
be active cuz that's why I do well when
I get moving that's where I do well you
know and try not to be afraid of what's
going on oh they had this Logan Paul I
don't have you heard about this kid it's
Logan Paul fella
you know first name last some people
have that last name first name where
they switch it up you know they had this
kid in our town named Sanders Benny that
was his name Sanders Benny and obviously
whoever named today his name was Benny
Sanders but they [ __ ] it up somehow
because all of his siblings had last
name Sanders and then this [ __ ] world
a dude has Sanders Benny I mean if you
want somebody to have you know what's it
call we are dyslexic
once you [ __ ] start them right there
and he had dyslexia this dude I mean
this dude you asked him to spin in a
circle you wouldn't see him for probably
about two minutes this dude getting lost
man this guy would get lost this guy he
could get lost on a twin bed
this guy could get lost on a twin bed
this is something we had that you know
just something little bit wrong with him
sanders bene and he but that's what this
logan paul kid you know he's a name is
wrong first of all so right out of the
gate you know that some wrong things
might happen to him you know i had this
belief that things that that if they
name you a certain way when you're a
child or you know babies that are
conceived a certain way they can certain
things are gonna happen in their life
you know like if you're a dog if you
were conceived in the doggy style
position i'm not gonna be surprised if
twenty years later you're stealing cars
or stealing boat radios and drinking hot
vodka you know when you're supposed to
be babysitting or you're supposed to be
running a children's care center during
the summer you know i'm not gonna be
surprised if you were conceived in the
doggy style position if you're out there
doing like doing that you know snorting
adderall and [ __ ] filling out fake
magazine subscriptions for all your
friends i'm not gonna be surprised yeah
and this logan paul kid he is a youtuber
and he has millions and millions of
subscribers and we don't have that many
we only have about nineteen thousand so
if you're listening and haven't
subscribed please do but logan you know
he caters his audience I guess his
younger skews younger than him
I think he's twenty of twenty one years
old so he was in Japan and he went to a
popular place in Japan where it's a
forest where people commit suicide and
from everything that I've learned and I
could be wrong I'm happy to be wrong no
problem with it
from everything that I've learned or
what little I know suicide in Japan is
you know it's there's a lot of Honor
people in Japan have a lot of honor and
you know and people will commit suicide
there apparently when they feel like
they are not living up to the potential
of themselves you know and I don't know
if is he's exactly the same why we do it
in America I don't know why no matter
what it's sad it's sad when somebody
feels that broken when somebody feels
that much pain that they're gonna end
their own life well Logan went to a
forest where people do this and he was
making jokes you know the guys 21 years
old and a lot of his
a lot of his subscribers and listeners
were upset and people are upset people
are commenting people work and I mean
millions of people like and apparently
like he's now gotten more followers
because more people are jumping on and
see what's even going on with this kid I
mean this this is a 21 year old you know
and he's growing up and he's he's he's
seeing new things you know he's in new
environments he probably has an ego I
mean at 21 years old
you told me you wouldn't have an ego if
he had 15 or 30 million YouTube
followers and everybody thought you was
the the cat's butthole
you know you would in a heartbeat any of
us would so if he's you know making
off-color jokes or whatever he's doing
whatever makes him think in his head he
can do these things it could be
adolescence how about that you ever made
a poor choice you were 21 every choice I
made when I was 21 was four and I was
poor so you know it just it's amazing
that and now like people who are
advertisers are saying they don't to be
associated with them advertisers are
bail it's like I don't understand
sometimes why when the going gets tough
that as a society and as viewers and as
an industry of entertainment that that's
when we bail or when things get real
like this guy is too whatever myth
however many subscribers he has he makes
a mistake that's that's when is a good
time to learn I don't care what it is
that is a great time to learn when
somebody's [ __ ] up it's easy to watch
somebody just do great all the time oh
you're still doing great
amazing I don't care about that [ __ ]
anymore somebody that's always great I
don't care about that you know why
because I don't believe that I don't
believe that and here's a kid he [ __ ]
up that's when we have a chance to learn
you know that's when people should be
like what's going on here how do we
learn from this scenario I'm not going
to judge the dude you know I'm a I've do
a lot of weird stuff
a lot of wild stuff man you know I
remember I had a cousin when I was young
that was blind and he's still blind and
I remember telling him there were
dragons outside and until you've seen a
blind kid tried to hide from dragons in
an open field you haven't seen anything
and I still feel bad about stuff like
that but I made mistakes I wouldn't do
that now I wouldn't do that now because
it's not fun and it's not cool to watch
somebody blind try to hide from dragons
that they think are real you know and we
just make poor choices like I remember
when they have that show it was like
about 17 children or whatever it's like
a religious family that had 17 children
and and I didn't see the show much I
worked at Yahoo for about three years
doing their daily show and so we would
watch a lot of unscripted television
reality TV and we would make little
clickable stories on it for yahoo.com I
used to like Yahoo now I think that they
are they are way too biased and they're
not realistic but I used to like Yahoo
we make these stories and so we watch
the show 17 and Counting you remember
the show and then something happened on
the show a couple things happened one
some this family had 17 children they
were very religious and I remember I was
when I did see the show I would I was
intrigued by just thinking what's it
like to be in a family with that many
kids because you have to meet you have
to talk to 15 people before you even
leave your house so were you by the time
you get outdoors and enter the world are
you just fed up with people or you you
know what is that like and and and would
you feel like our parents able to love
that many kids you know if you're like
the youngest kid at that point is there
enough love in the household from the
oldest children to help to help fill in
whatever you know love is too overly
divided a 2mo of what are the parents
love it's two divided by so many kids or
the older kids able to help fill that in
a little bit by
supportive of the younger children these
are just thoughts that I had about this
show well then some things came out
where one of the kids had touched
another one of the children and that's
unfortunate and it wasn't rape from
everything I know from everything I
remember reading hearing about it wasn't
you know it was it was inappropriate and
it was it was children but it was
children it was adolescent kids and you
don't think when I was you don't
remember when I was young I remember I
would hug my sister too much
I would our I would hug her I didn't
know what was going on but I would just
hug her sometimes and I felt like years
later I would feel like it was
inappropriate maybe now did I touch her
did I do anything like that no but I do
remember just having some weird feelings
and it was just cuz I was going through
adolescence I was going I don't I was
going through puberty I don't know what
I was going through but I do remember
feeling you know just feeling odd or
feeling strange and my sister was young
and so I remember yeah just I hugged her
too much you know I just I would always
carry her around even after she was too
big it was a little bit just weird you
know it was weird
I remember walking in on two of my
nephews one time who were you know
touching each other's butts or something
you know and that was just wow but they
were kids they were 11 years old I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna you know there were
kids so I remember when this when this
happened to that family I remember
thinking to myself man this is
unfortunate and this this show was on
The Learning Channel but I thought this
was this is a great time to learn
because I bet a lot of families and a
lot of people out there I've had
something strange that happened in their
childhood with a sibling that they don't
feel like was or you know that they are
they're uncertain about how they feel
about it and that's when they cut the
program off that's when TLC I think it
was TLC got rid of the program and I'm
like what the hell
oh and one of the other one of the
children the older boy had just
gotten accused of being on like a an
adulterous dating website Adult Friend
Finder that's what it was called and I
could relate to that surely I'd browse
past that site before you know I'm no
angel and I wasn't even married and I
ain't not browse past it but I remember
I met a man who was on it one time and I
was working in comedy on the road and he
was so addicted to being on this site
and getting in these weird scenarios
that I already had enough weird in my
life I didn't need that but I remember
thinking when these allegations came out
in these things came out about this huge
family I remember thinking this is Wow
now The Learning Channel is really gonna
be able to help because this is gonna be
a great time to learn this can be a
great time to see what happens here but
suddenly the show is off here these
people are horrible that was the overall
vibe there they're not Christian you
know or they're not they were because
the religion was Christian and I'm just
thinking to myself what a shitty time to
bail what a shitty time to bail as a
viewer what a shitty time to bail is a
network what a shitty time to bail as
someone who's interested or someone who
wants to learn when somebody's having a
tough time and that's you know and I
don't know this Logan Paul kid Paul
Logan whatever it is Ted Theodore Logan
that's an old reference to some of you
guys but you know I don't know this kid
but when he makes a mistake that's when
I want to tune in that's when I saw the
first video I've seen of this kids outs
the first video of this I've seen of
this child's of this boy outside of the
watch the one where he was in the force
and he was making fun of them you know
the body that he killed themselves
definitely out of line but out of line
for a 21 year old that has the you know
that it's probably full of ego and you
know probably doesn't even know who he
is because he's growing up in the
spotlight not surprised not shocked
almost it would almost be out of line if
he didn't do something like that and
this is the time that it's it's it's
those times when Hollywood so weird to
me and I know that YouTube it's not
Hollywood
but you know probably any movie deals
that he had going like or things like
that that were in the works I'm sure
like all those people are like oh what a
you know this guy's a piece of [ __ ] but
that's when you need support that's and
that's when as a viewer that's when I
want to get on board when something real
is happening when I got the ability to
learn you know cuz otherwise all they're
showing me is by pulling shows where
[ __ ] when things get real all they show
me is oh wow things are real that's
there's something wrong with that
there's something wrong when you know oh
something happens in a house like this
with you know where the children
something goes awry now maybe the family
didn't want to do it anymore that could
be a possibility and I don't know that
but from everything I remember that
wasn't the case with the religious
family you know it's just like oh this
is [ __ ] up is it you got 15 kids in a
house I don't see how you even flip a
light switch without touching somebody's
ass I don't even see how you reach for
the frigerator door without grabbing at
it on accident with 15 17 kids in a
house so some of that's just like just
so it's just so lame it's just lame and
it's not helpful when things get real
and that's when that's when Hollywood
and these and people that just are
holier-than-thou that's when they bail
that's when they bail oh you're bailing
now that [ __ ] got pretty real it's
supposed to be the Learning Channel
oh now you're bailing so there's just
that's what I feel about this Logan Paul
scenario it's like if if I'm you're
telling me a 21 year old made a mistake
or did something we or two did something
[ __ ] up also if you're letting your
kids watch a 21 year old vlog all the
time and you're shocked that they see
something crazy you're telling me that
the 21 year old is the one at fault you
can go eat a can of pickled giraffe
nipples dude
cuz that's [ __ ] bizarre that's crazy
that's like trying to pass a square turd
brother good luck good luck if that's
the way you want to live your life
because I would be shocked if a 21 year
old didn't make some poor choices oh
that's when I would be shocked so those
are my thoughts on that
you know you telling me you haven't
[ __ ] up and yeah maybe your kids
shouldn't be watching and maybe this is
where his show evolves into something
else you know the kids gonna change he's
not maybe he's not a kid anymore maybe
he's not a kid anymore this Logan Paul
you know Sanders Benny I mean first of
all you what the [ __ ] you named him last
name first would you expect you didn't
expect him to get things a little mixed
up talk to his parents first before you
talk to him I think what else man I'll
stay in the news here a little bit
there's someone pooping in people's
yards and I'm not trying to be gross
here but I saw this on this is on the
Fox News website don't watch Fox News no
do I go to their website sometimes yeah
I go to all of my you go to Yahoo I
don't go there anymore but yeah woman
was pooping in people's yards out there
in Arkansas this is news I'm surprised
somebody isn't [ __ ] in somebody's
yard in Arkansas you know I was in El
Paso I'm also be surprised if if I saw
an article that said somebody wasn't
turd now you know making a little bit of
that belt grow and belt out of their
bottom I'd be surprised if somebody
wasn't doing that called the mad pooper
makes vile mess and driveway Arkansas
woman said what do you mean vile mess
you mean duty what are you talking about
vile mess
is she a sorcerer does she have a
crock-pot you know does it have a bird
gizzard in it
and snakes and snails and puppy-dog
tails what do you mean vile mess here's
a lady she said we were upset when we
found out it was not a dog it was a
person who'd been jogging down the
street ran up between our two cars
defecated and ran away
well at least they did it between two
cars you know I'll give them that but
yeah I don't think it's cool to be
[ __ ] in somebody else's yard if
you're not a dog
so I'd set a trap out there I put it
maybe some toilet tissue that's hooked
up some jumper cables you know I'm
saying let's find out huh let's see them
[ __ ] when they got that tricity rolling
through him let's see him blowing out
they but when they about maybe two or
three hundred volts in cuz I'll tell you
this it's hard to turn it out when you
got that tricity on you you know I
remember we still electrocute each other
a little bit and try to pee and that was
hard and so I can only imagine trying to
go full throttle you know trying to do
sup the things to get a little things
could get a little wild but that was a
little bit more news man oh here we go
right here man fighting for his life
after chasing a monkey that took his
Steelers hat I'll read it to you real
quick Jeff a native of Florida course
Florida dude everything dangerous
happens down there a lot of uh now
Florida you know definitely PDF files
for first 48 hours they definitely shoot
a lot down there what else and Ferris
wheels but Jeff a native of Florida who
lives in Bali is fighting to stay alive
after he fell from a roof while chasing
a monkey who stole his favorite Steelers
hat villagers rushed him to a local
hospital where he was diagnosed with
severe damage to his spinal cord and is
paralyzed from the chest chest down
no news if he was able to recover his
hat from the monkey hmm well he better
get used to wearing hats now
unfortunately because there's not a lot
of you know hats and scars if you're you
know if he is unfortunately sadly and
I'm not trying to make light of this but
if he turns up quadriplegic or something
like that and
hats and scarves are going to be you
know some of the more popular toppings
or accoutrements for somebody like that
or a shawl so he'll be able to probably
get you know probably you know you want
to worry about as much but but man you
don't chase monkeys you know I'm telling
you you don't [ __ ] with chimps you do
not [ __ ] with chimps dude when a chimp
looks at you he looks at you like a Tony
Roma's all you are to a chimp is a place
for ribs a chimp will crack you in half
yeah a chimp will eat you he will eat
soup out of your butt cheeks while you
watch they are violent animals and I
watched him I watched a chimp this is
true I was in Malaysia when I was a
student we we traveled and we went to
Malaysia and I saw a chimp I saw this
was a rubenesque black black girl and
she was wild you know how she can be
wild and she this chimp came up and
stole a bag of chips and there was a
look that the chimp and the girl gave
each other and that girl shrunk down she
knew that she had met her match and this
chimp this chimp just just this straight
up chimp chip this chip chimp he just
snatched him and this girl Dondre was
her name and Dondre looked at him and
that chimp looked at Dondre and Dondre
shut down you don't [ __ ] with chimps man
maybe that's what you do you got
somebody [ __ ] in your yard in
Arkansas let a chimp loose let's see him
let's see him let's see him out there DK
ting defect Katyn when they got chimps
out there in the yard you try to [ __ ]
around a chimp you will not
we had some great calls that came in I'm
gonna get to those in just a second and
I want to tell you that I've been
fortunate enough recently I got Chris
Perez we got a Latino gentleman now
that's helping with the podcast and we
got wild Cory and Cory I don't know
something I think maybe he got it you
know he got a hit uh something he's
coming in you know he got kind of wild
he got that Boo Radley and I'm a little
bit but he's you know he's adventurous
and he's helping out on the on the
Thursday episode but what I should have
done if I could go back in time and I
still may have to if these fellows don't
work out but what I should have done was
go to zip recruiter does your business
have any New Year's resolutions well
here's an important one every business
should consider make your hiring process
more efficient and more effective
oh you mean faster and a friendlier yeah
this year let's zip recruiter help no
one has done a better job of
transforming how you find the right
talents then zip recruiter has zip
recruiter posts your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards with just
one click
no wonder 80% of employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day I'm not
talking about a man showing up you know
who just who you know maybe doesn't you
know he doesn't know all the letters of
the alphabet and he you know he thin is
his motive his parents are mystics or
you know with or [ __ ] wood wizards
people who live out in the woods and
think they know [ __ ] now I'm talking
about a quality candidate and right now
my listeners can post jobs on zip
recruiter for free that's right for free
just go to zip recruiter dot-com slash
tpw that's zip recruiter com /tp W all
right let's take a call all right here
here we go yovan I just call man I heard
how many times you were I guess are you
probably goddamn idiot 300 and she's
calling because I have I've ran out of
gas in my life over
thirty times because I didn't know and
I've mentioned this on a past episode I
didn't know people don't run out of gas
they don't tell you that [ __ ] when
you're growing up you know there that's
one of the problems they don't have a
class at school that tells you things
things you need to know you know you
can't you can't eat you can't have as
much soup as you want or it'll start
coming up and filling up in your throat
you can't just go forever on the first
amount of gas you get you know you can't
babysit kids and lock them in their
rooms you know they don't tell there's a
lot of stuff that they don't tell you
and they don't have a class on that [ __ ]
so yeah I didn't know that you couldn't
run out of gas and I have done it before
I appreciate you calling onward
once you get down to a quarter to fill
the [ __ ] tank up how many times you
gotta call somebody for help man damn um
a lot of times actually I've called a
lot of people for help and it is weird
when you call them for help for running
out of the gas because people think that
it's something that doesn't happen
anymore because I guess maybe it doesn't
happen anymore but let's hear more I
should smack that goddamn mud off your
[ __ ] head I Love You Man I would
smack you out of love of course [ __ ]
Jesus Christ do like people don't know
to gas like that man you don't just run
in the car to the [ __ ] shower guys
dude come on
if you risky you do it boo boo and I
stay risky out there cuz who do you want
think about this though and I appreciate
your calling you got a pretty voice and
you sound cute but who do you want you
want a man out there just riding around
with a full tank all the time
or you want that that that musket musk
musk man out there who's out there
fuming and zooming you know out there
pedal-to-the-metal with nothing in the
tank maybe a cat that's what you want
I'll pick up a hitchhiker
cuz I don't want to die alone son you
know what I'm saying
I want to be out that's lucky maybe
that's the kind of man you need a little
bit you need to quit riding around with
these fellas that got the full tank and
got you know a concern you know water in
the back and a flashlight [ __ ] a
flashlight I got three matches if we
don't see it after I light those
[ __ ] then it's
gonna get us cuz that's all I have but
I'm that Wild Ride you know I'm that
loose cannon you come in here man you
like that the sugar you're like um you
like the Sugar Ray Leonard of
compliments you hit me in and say
something sweet
cuz Sugar Ray Leonard seemed like a
sweet man you know if you look at him
he's very sweet man if you hear him
speak in person very kind man but that
man could kill you and she sound like
that she sound like something sweet that
could kill you you know she she sound
like that diabetes right there you're
goddamn tanker it's not that hard and I
appreciated you're right it's not that
hard to fill my gas tank up and I'm
gonna try to do it more often and
actually yesterday I was down to like
about 17 miles and I stopped and filled
it up instead of taking that risk and
taking that chance so thank you for
calling let's hear more here we go what
up you my name is Cole I'm from San
Diego California thank you for calling
Cole I'll be down in La Jolla in a
couple of weeks man so if you feel like
coming out to the show let me know talk
to you then here we go more call 26
years old my issue or whatever that I
thought you might be able to speak on
I've been sober about a year and I guess
congratulations man
my friend just got a year yesterday and
uh and honestly matter brought it's here
to modbus because it was cool to see
somebody you know stick with something
and stay committed to it homeward I
guess one of my issues has been like not
being able to stay focused on on
recovery like making finding a woman or
or just getting laid whatever making
that kind of my higher power as opposed
to making myself growing myself and
looking to fine you don't happiness fell
for it from somebody else
what yeah there's you know I appreciate
you calling Cole and I this is an exact
problem that I'm having right now in my
life you know you know I was falling for
this girl and it's just been tough
because I I my foundation in my own life
was
that good and I started to put her into
this role you know like a little bit of
like a not a savior but I just I was
trying to get I was trying to build on
something where my foundation wasn't
solid that's it
it's as simple as it is you know and and
it's just hard to do you know it's
dangerous when you're we got one guy
coming out to meet you in the morning
saying that the the land that you're
living on is quicksand and you got
another guy coming out in the evening
another woman coming out in the evening
and she's a contractor and that's what I
was doing I was contracting on quicksand
you know I mean I was hot you know I was
I was trying to do blueprints and I was
out there in the baltic ocean and so
that's the same thing that I'm dealing
with and for me I noticed for me this
might not be your scenario but for me if
I don't get if I don't get the second
one right I don't get the blueprints
right then it's gonna be it's not
impossible but it's gonna be tough it's
gonna be a lot tougher for me to stay
tried-and-true into something that I you
know in a relationship with someone that
I care about because I if I don't know
how much I care about myself or where to
go when I don't care about myself if I
don't have like a reservoir or process
and some people like will do what the
[ __ ] you talking about dude well I'm
just talking about that I don't have
those things you know I wasn't born with
those things I wasn't taught those
things when I was young and so I have to
learn them now I have to learn them as
an adult and uh and that's okay you know
I'm just uh I'm a seventh-grade adult
man that's what I feel like sometimes
but I appreciate that call and I would
just you know I would try to fight it
and there's other groups you can get in
there's an essay SLA a group sex and
love addicts and that can they people in
there could talk to you about your
problem I mean I remember dude I would I
was so nervous about dating I remember
that I was in love before I even went to
pick the girl up if I finally got a girl
to go on a date with me and I got some I
mean I look you could always catch a
little bit of trim you know
you could always catch a little bit of
that hot poke you know you could always
catch that that's out there but if you
got a girl you were interested in at all
I was in love before I even picked her
up because something in my brain had
already there was no it just you know it
just didn't leave room for things to
grow it didn't leave room for things to
grow or things to feel normal
it didn't really matter what our
relationship was gonna be like it just
mattered if how much did I need someone
and then I would latch you know I would
latch but it's tough dude it's tough and
those you know sometimes the you know
you're you know being sober from women
is what you need and I'm not saying that
to you I'm not telling you that but I've
heard that from other people that can be
the thing but I appreciate you calling
Cole and helping us think about that
today and and you're not alone out there
and it's such a beautiful I mean look
it's not like you're putting something
Shady
in front of your sobriety it's not like
you're saying you know you're collecting
you know Civil War cannons or something
freaking you know that and that's you're
doing something you're at least you're
out there trying to meet women but I
find if you can for me I'm learning that
if I can get my brain and my heart good
first then I'll be able to really thrive
out there in a committed relationship
and in and with somebody that I love and
that's something that I'm hoping to be
able to do honest they do damn I sound
like a straight [ __ ] sack of urine
out here today but I'm getting I'm
getting a leaky out here you know I'm
getting a little bit just you know
whatever I feel sometimes I talking
about some of this stuff let's take
another call here here we go hey Theo
what's up my name is Andrew from Prince
Edward Island Canada I want to address a
dark arts but thank you for calling
Andrew and thank you for calling from
Canada and a lot I think a lot of
Americans are gonna start defecting to
Canada soon and I hope that Canada you
will accept us you know we are in a
country as men
where it's hard to you know we're not
allowed to have a lot of feelings
anymore we are not allowed to be our
innate selves we are under attack by you
know this this idea of what America is
supposed to be like but we are not a you
know but if we speak up about dealing
with what America really is like then we
are shunned so let us know if we can
come up there and we probably need like
a new Underground Railroad and it's
gonna be firm in escaping to the great
white north so hope you'll have us ah
onward here we go Andrew thank you for
calling my wife is overweight I was
overweight
okay wife overweighting you're
overweight or was overweight onward we
both agreed on it I've lost the weight
and she hasn't Canada I want to okay I'm
gonna start I'm gonna back it up a
little bit here we go again
no address a dark arts my wife is
overweight I was overweight we both
agreed on it I've lost the weight and
she hasn't and there's no way for me to
bring it up without being the [ __ ] or
the emotional abuse of man but I'm just
not attracted to her and I don't want to
[ __ ] her so I do turn to pointless I
don't know I'm just attracted to a
certain thing and she was it and now
she's not and I don't know how to tell
her that she's got to get back to that
Wow wow man Andrew thank you for calling
I mean this kind of like is almost in a
weird way a summation of a lot of the
things it not a summation but it's it's
a very specific moment you know that
kind of equates a lot of the stuff we're
talking about I don't even know if
equates is the right word but you know
what I don't give a [ __ ] if it's the
right word you know what I'm saying
ha you know and maybe some of our
listeners will have ideas and thoughts
about this you know and I know you're
not asking me to put it out there Andrew
but I'm gonna put it out there and if
you decide to call and let me know that
you don't want us to put it out there
you know let me know that but you know
that's heavy you know you're what you
guys made this deal both agreed to lose
the way
you lost the way than she did and now
you don't feel sexually attracted to her
and so you're going to pornography man
cuz I know once you get trapped if you
get trapped in pornography that can be
tough and that's something you obviously
it doesn't sound like something you want
it sound like something you're upset
about man how do you bring that up to
her you're the only thing that I could
think is that you I mean for one you
just try to love her you know you try to
love where she's at you try to love her
just be loving you know in the moments
that you are interacting with each other
you just be loving it's probably not
gonna be easy maybe before you go in the
house each time you get home you just
take a moment a pause or something and
remind yourself that you you want to be
loving whatever that means even if it's
not for you can be loving to her but
it's not really even if that's for you
just to not get an argument to not have
a weird give a weird look sort of behave
weirdly towards her you know and maybe
I'm thinking that you could try to
inspire her in other ways you know maybe
do some joint classes together or
something like that you know with that
said over time if that doesn't change
and you're not attracted to her then you
decide well how long do I stay in this
environment and how long does she start
just she will she want to stay at this
environment because then what happens is
I've noticed that you can start to one
of you guys will start resenting the
other one or both people can resent each
other yeah it's a that's a weird
that's a weird little pond to wait in
brah mmm and maybe some of our listeners
are more experienced with that you know
and you know and it's it's it's tough
because you want a partner and I want
this I want a partner that that you know
inspires me I want that but then I also
I have to be that you know I have to be
that at the same time I don't appreciate
this calm and this is you know this got
a lot of stuff on it because then you
don't feel sexually attracted
you know and it's just it's wild out
there
it's wild out there in them dick and
heart streets this [ __ ] ain't easy pop
pop but if you guys have thoughts or
suggestions for Andrew let's hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three you know his wife
has a physique that is not attractive to
him now
you know they've discussed Fitness she
doesn't she hasn't done it yet and he is
resorting to pornography and then I get
scared for you cuz pornography boy
that's that booty trap and you get out
there and they you know they got ladies
spraying milk out of new each other's
mouths and you know dressing up like
swans and you know hold catching us you
know you know chewing gobstoppers with
their butt holes and everything and it's
wild and that can be you then you can be
that you can get crispy out there you
can get really crispy let's take one
more call here let's see where we're at
we're kind of lifting up in time a
little bit but let's take um maybe maybe
more than one let's see what we got and
I appreciate you guys calls you know I
probably would have talked about more of
exactly what happened this past weekend
but oh I did go you know what I did all
weekend I stay committed to what my plan
was you know I had a couple meetings
that I went to in the morning each day
and you know I talked about like some of
these AAA meanings and different men's
groups and [ __ ] that I go to and look
you don't have to be able to relate to
me on that this podcast isn't for sober
people this podcast isn't I don't give a
[ __ ] who this podcast is for you know I
mean I I do in the sense that it's for
you know it's for its for us man
it's for us to laugh and feel and try
and be able to do the same to at the
same time you know cuz I you know so
much of my life on the outside has been
at times sad and on the and on the
inside has been fun and on the end times
and on the inside at times has been sad
on the outside and has been fun and
[Music]
and that's what life is that's what it
is you don't know which one and for me I
never knew which one I was gonna get win
and I never knew how I was gonna react
if the world was good I didn't know if I
was gonna feel okay to even enjoy it and
most of the time I didn't you know but
this is a place where I can talk about
that you know and I know sometimes this
podcast maybe even the funniest and [ __ ]
dude well you know what I'll [ __ ] your
cousin bro all right I don't even give a
dang I don't care if it's a man or a
woman dude and I'm not even gay bro so
now what you bend your cousin over put a
sheet over them okay I'll run up with an
erection right when I get there you pull
the sheet BAM I'm inside and I don't
give a damn I don't give a cat's [ __ ]
whisker fart I don't care I'll [ __ ] your
cousin dude if you're gonna be rude I'll
[ __ ] your cousin and that's just where
I'm at you know because I'm just
whatever dude but Andrew I appreciate
that call let's take another call here
oh we're in Cleveland
quick Johnny from Cleveland big Jay from
Cleveland this went oh and 16 your
football team went oh and 16 why have a
team pick a different sport dude don't
you realize that Cleveland Browns if you
went oh in 16 at football pick a
different sport
maybe all our baseball team maybe all
our synchronized swimmers have you
thought about that
maybe you guys are should do baking or
or woodwork you know did everybody
graduate from shop class I'm just saying
if you're not good at football then
don't keep doing it do something else
make a new sport
what about violent chess I could see you
guys out there knight Knight takes pawn
with a [ __ ] leg drop
I'm just saying Cleveland Browns if
you're not good at football then be good
at something else try something else
onward Jonny the topic for you chicks
getting on dating apps and looking for
that sugar daddy basically putting
yourself in the odd sexual situations
that most people wouldn't usually do you
know if they were financially stable you
know in the old days I guess you just
had to go out on the streets and
prostitute yourself you know
now that's becoming less and less we do
it all over the internet people are
hitting these dating apps really just
looking for money you know on tenders
you'll see that people just put their
venom O's in there they won't take their
Instagram it looks like the Twitter but
I'll just toss the memo in there it's
like all right see what you do it might
actually what you're looking for you
know in fact okay I appreciate the call
and you're talking about girls that are
you know just being sugar daddies and a
lot of them rot on tinder and I'll tell
you this a lot of them live out here and
I think it's it's always been there
some type of prostitution at some level
it's very vague I mean for Hollywood who
also has you know there's a lot of
women's rights movements and stuff like
that and look I'm no one supports a
woman more than I do I mean you know I
grew up watching my mother worked 50
hours a week so that we could eat you
know and I'd even get to have my mother
because she chose to work instead of
collect welfare because she wanted to
show just by example you know in that
and and for that we had a sacrifice of
emotional connection so I support there
was you know but there was the the
hardest-working man I've ever known as
my mother you know my mother works hard
and in you and you know and so I support
the movement the idea that women need to
feel empowered but at the same time you
have all these women who you know all
these sex accusations and this and that
at the same time here in Hollywood you
have billboards up around town for sugar
daddy websites which are basically
websites that tell women that connect
women with men with money in exchange
for a vague scenario where one is
expecting sex possibly and one is
expecting
possibly to me that sounds dangerous
when I if a man shows up and he doesn't
know what he's supposed to be expecting
or giving and a woman shows up and they
don't know what to be they're expecting
or giving how is that creating positive
and how was it it's not even a clean
interaction that doesn't sound look if I
have a daughter one day she chooses to
be out selling her body for sex you know
God forbid that's not something that I
want but if she's if that's where she's
at in the world or in her life or
something that's going on and it's a
clean it's a straight-up deal you know I
mean this is such a weird thing I got
myself into but I would have to support
her of course I'd be trying to get her
self-help groups and different types of
things and stuff like that in getting
her out of those dark hearts but I will
but but that but to have a daughter
wandering into a place not knowing what
to expect
money's may be on the table sex is may
be on the table
[ __ ] that sounds scary to me and those
billboards are all over Hollywood
so that's where sometimes I'm just like
Hollywood fails us when the idea is one
thing but the reality is something else
or something that they don't want to or
when it gets real that's when there
there's no no one talks about that no
one talks about that because advertising
is just an extension and PR press the
newspaper it's all it's an extension of
Hollywood you know that most of it but
yeah it's scary man and it's a lot of
women are out there doing it and do a
fall term I don't fault them you know
III know some that that seemed to be
able to do it healthfully and under
something that have gotten involved in
it seem like they can't you know I know
some that I have friends are out there
that are addicted to those websites that
are meeting up with women two and three
times a week you know these sugar daddy
websites but you know I mean a
prostitution
the beginning of time I don't think that
it's bad I don't think it's bad if it's
a clean deal I think it gets sketchy
when you're not sure what does that the
circumstances are that seems sketchy to
me all right where are we at here you
know we had a couple more calls I'm
gonna I'm gonna put this one call in and
this call came in a couple weeks ago and
I'm gonna be in Jacksonville next week
so I just want to put this in and I'll
just give us something all to you know
if you want to get out of yourself
you're already thinking about yourself
so much today and you're sick of
yourself because I get there sometimes
I'm sick on myself
I just want my brain to stop thinking
about me but it won't here we go yo Theo
my brother from another mother I got
high school sweetheart I lost my
opportunity to her ooh man dude there's
nothing fun or sometimes honestly even
if it was a fiasco dude I remember I
mean everybody has a wild virginity
story and I kind of lost my virginity a
couple times because I couldn't lose it
because every time I would get right up
by the you know by that Vova Vova you
know my body would just spray out do you
remember one time I fainted dude just
came to or just you know woke up you
know and then it's later dude and uh you
know I've always had them you know I've
had that fainting goat syndrome I've
talked to you guys about it before where
I get so much anxiety hearing sex I'm
just holding my breath and just [ __ ]
away like a little goat and then I'll
pass out well but sometimes nothing's
funner than thinking back to them days
when you're out there just you know when
you was just 70% nuts and [ __ ] you know
when your whole body was fuelled by this
little metal detector but the metal was
chicks and tits and you was just
detecting it everywhere dude you know
Wow
I mean I would [ __ ] a woman's haircut if
it had a wet barrette in it you know
what I'm saying that's where I was that
but let's hear more your call and
as that happened she [ __ ]
flippy-floppy and she cheated on me her
and that dude ended up getting knocked
up while she was still in high school
she married him popped out another kid
but uh he okay so you were dating a girl
you lost your virginity to her then she
hooked up with another guy and had a
child still in high school
whoo this could be Arkansas is she's
[ __ ] in people's yards now let's
hear more
he's piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] car salesman
yeah I mean there's some rough car
salesman out there unless you're done in
Natchez Mississippi I got a buddy named
Gulf South auto he works over there the
deal daddy and you should go see him
he's a decent man decent fella over
there deal daddy onward
you know that's my opinion you know not
all car salesmen are [ __ ] that's
true dude there's probably four or five
percent of Miss decent homework thing is
every two years she hits me up and she's
like oh hey you know [ __ ] Oh getting
separated and [ __ ] and then we just have
a blowout and then you know stops
talking to me and then hits me up in two
or three years yeah I know am I wasting
my [ __ ] time
she keeps saying she's getting separated
look dude look man you know she's not
getting separated if you've done this a
few times you know she's not getting
separated bro you know don't be my used
car salesman you got here trying to sell
me this used car of a story here and I'm
not mad at you I still love you but come
on man you know you're just taking that
thing for a test drive every couple
years and y'all meeting up behind the
sizzler behind whatever behind that wall
green and y'all out there testing each
other's crotches out for a half hour
you know we're [ __ ] real quick
somewhere about a day's in come on man
I've been out there so you know she
ain't getting separated this is a lemon
of a car this story you selling me here
so look I think both y'all are using
each other for what y'all are using each
other for and I think you should be
grateful enough that after that bad
you gave her that first run that first
you know hit with that Thunder stick
that she left you after you know that
she's giving you other chances to make
up for it with another couple lightning
strikes you know I think that's all it
is man so I think just you know both it
seems like both you guys are on the up
and up and dealing with things I would
just be honest with her she gets real
real then you get real but don't lie I
just try not to lie if you can help it
man and if you can't help but at least
try to be a really good person while you
do it you know because sometimes you
just can't help things but that's it
today man I appreciate you guys calling
I'd love it if we had some thoughts for
that for for Andrew who's no longer too
attracted to his wife if you want to hit
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three I want to thank you
guys for being supportive I want to
thank my boy Chris Perez for being out
here and getting it done today and just
want to wish you guys well if your team
still in the NFL playoffs come get these
Saints because we're gonna do something
alvin kamara bleh and I'm excited to see
these games next week good luck to
Jacksonville my boy coleus Campbell out
there getting it done you know he gives
the best out postgame interviews and
they got a good squad and if your team
lost that's okay you got time to chill
you'll be a fantasy next year I'm
excited to see what sport the Cleveland
Browns play next year Thank You JP for
calling in and telling me to stop being
a PI and I'm gonna try that I'm gonna
try not to run out of gas this week you
know Cole if you want to be sober be
sober if you but it's right now whatever
you're doing it doesn't it doesn't seem
like it's your primary goal it could be
one of your goals but look trucks I'm
telling you from a guy who's I've made
it not my goal and guess what it's not
my goal so when it's your goal it's your
goal but as long as you if you make an
inch towards it every day then it's
still a goal you just got to make an
inch
Andrew will have some tough stuff for
you hopefully on Thursday's episode we
appreciate you guys :
you guys be good to yourselves you
probably deserve a sire if this
is a downer episode but you know what
dude whatever there's so much bad [ __ ]
out there that if all that's all this
was was more bad [ __ ] than [ __ ]
bienvenidos pop beat
[Music]
celebrate
be good to yourselves guys
right
[Music]
you